-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-winning writer
and an Emmy- and
Golden Globe-nominated actor.
His children's book, "Zilot
& Other Important Rhymes,"
is on sale now.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend Bob Odenkirk,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Bob.
-Thank you, man.
Great to be here.
-You are a SAG member.
You're a WGA member.
You were very active
on the picket lines this summer.
-I really was.
That's your job, right?
-That is your job.
And you did a great job.
-Well, I --
This is my third strike.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Chuckles ]
Badge of honor.
I -- You know,
I know what to do.
You go out to where
the other writers are
and you walk in circles,
and that's what you do.
And that's your part
of the job.
-Did you find that
as you get older,
you realize that if you walk in
the same direction for too long,
one hip just starts to hurt?
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah. I really -- I'm like,
"Guys, we got to switch it up.
This is -- We're going to be
feeling this tomorrow."
-That's right. And if you
turn around and go the other way
or you just switch people
that you're with,
then you get other
screenplays...from them.
-Do you like the camaraderie
of the picket line?
-I love the camaraderie.
-It's really nice.
I mean, writers kind of
are loners, sort of.
They kind of are in their lives.
But then you put them in a line
and give them something to hate
together,
they become best buds,
and we're all chums.
-You're a pro now,
but did you feel like a rookie
in the '88 strike?
-Oh, I was such an ass[bleep].
-Uh-huh.
-I was such a jerk.
Like, I had been hired
at "Saturday Night Live"
only a few shows
before the strike.
What right did I have?
[ Chuckles ]
And -- And I go to the strike
with my friend Robert Smigel.
-Fantastic writer.
-One of the great
writers of all time.
And we get there
and somebody is speaking.
Somebody is giving a speech.
"We can do this! Hang in there!"
Some old guy is going on and on.
And I'm like,
"Who's this ass[bleep]?
This guy's a jerk.
Shut up already.
Let's start walking."
Somebody leans over
to me and goes,
"That's Budd Schulberg" --
one of the great writers
of the century.
And here I am,
this jerk from Naperville,
you know, giving him [bleep].
But I felt duly chastised,
and --
and I carried on with the job.
-You talked about
your early "SNL" time,
and you wrote a great book
about your career in comedy.
-Oh, thank you.
-And I heard you recently
tell the story,
and this actually has
some lore
about talking to a host,
because sometimes
you have to talk
to really accomplished actors.
-This was a great actor.
Jeremy Irons.
-I mean, to this day.
-One of the greats.
-And what was your --
what was your --
-My experience
was that I had written
a monologue for him
with someone else,
another writer.
And it was -- It took us,
you know,
a good 26 minutes to write it.
A lot of work went into it,
and it's his monologue
and he's been waiting
to do the show.
And he was so mad.
And he's reading it like this.
And I'm sitting right here.
He's right here.
His face is right here,
and he's looking at this thing
and he's going,
"You're making me do this?
I mean..."
And he starts complaining
and I have my recorder
and I press record,
and I get this monologue.
Which camera have I got?
"I mean, I can dance,
I can sing,
I can do Shakespeare,
I can juggle,
I can do anything,
and you have me do this?!"
[ Laughter ]
And, oh, it was the greatest.
It was so great. I loved it.
And then he had
to do that monologue.
[ Laughter ]
He did.
-I like -- Does that mean
you went back to Lorne's office,
and he's like,
"Does he like it?"
And you're like,
"He's good to go."
-"He loves it! He's on board."
-So, this is fantastic.
This is a book that has been,
I mean, two decades
in the making.
-It is. It is.
Zilot is a word
invented by my son Nate
when he was about six years old
for a blanket fort.
Okay?
You build blanket forts, right?
-Yeah, of course.
-With kids, they love it.
And you put a blanket
over a chair and a couch,
get inside, read books,
and the cat comes in
and it's the best.
And...
And my kids, we would read
a lot of books before bedtime.
And at a certain point, I said,
"Let's start
writing some poems."
And so we wrote a bunch
of really silly poems
and I kept them on a shelf.
And then 15 years later,
here comes a pandemic.
My daughter is an artist.
-So she drew all the pictures.
-She did all the illustrations,
and they're really beautiful.
-She did a wonderful job.
-Yeah. And we just sat down
and rewrote the poems
so they were good, because...
[ Laughter ]
-So you do have the original --
-I have the original book.
-This is what you kept on a
shelf, which is very impressive.
-This is what
I kept on the shelf.
-Yeah.
-"Old Time Rhymes" I called it.
I wanted the kids to feel like
they had really written a book.
By Dad, Nate and Erin.
And the truth is, look,
there were --
I knew there were, like,
10 good ones in here,
but most of the time
they're like this.
And here's one I just
picked out for you just
to show you my kids were not
born magically delicious.
[ Laughter ]
This one's called "Stay up."
[ Clears throat ]
"Eat some jello.
Go play the cello."
See those...?
[ Laughter ]
"Go out on the street
and meet an odd fellow.
Put a splash of toothpaste
in your comb if you dare,
so you can clean its teeth
while you fix your hair."
-Not terrible.
-Kind of...
Kind of clunky.
-So you obviously come back.
So it's pandemic.
You got the kids in the house.
-So I'm rewriting
one or two or three a week
and I'm knocking on
my daughter's door
like it's a, you know,
"30 Rock," an office.
"Where are those drawings?
Let's go.
You said you'd
have them yesterday!
Ahh."
-And what about Nate?
Was Nate sort of
getting off scot free?
-No, he. -- My son. I was like,
"I need 10 more poems."
-[ Laughs ]
When they were that age,
when they were writing poems
with you back then,
were they aware
that you were funny?
Were they entertained by you?
-Um...yeah.
-Okay.
-I was trying to be funny.
I was very silly
around the kids.
Really fun to do that.
And they kind of wised up.
They loved my silliness.
-Right.
-But one time when my daughter
was six, it was so great.
I was doing a character
in the mirror.
"Yeah, yeah, yeah,
time to go to school!
Let's go! Get on the bus!
Put on your clothes!"
And -- And I stopped,
and she goes...
"Bad."
[ Laughter ]
Six year old. You know?
I loved it.
-And you started
your recorder again.
You're like...
-"Come on."
-"I'd like to get this on tape."
-"I got a monologue for you."
-I do know that there are
a lot of kids books these days.
I would imagine it's a very
tough market to sell one.
-Well, usually it is.
But this month
we got very lucky.
All the other kids books
coming out are just terrible.
[ Laughter ]
-Now...
we didn't believe you
when we heard...
-Yeah, they're awful.
-And so we went and --
And you had mentioned --
-And you bought a few.
You just randomly bought --
-I couldn't believe
that these were actual titles,
because you did hit
the jackpot that your book --
-I just got lucky.
I just got lucky.
-Like, here's -- here's
a new book that is out.
-This one's coming out.
-It's called
"Nothing But Sharp Edges."
[ Laughter ]
-Why would you make this?
-I mean, show --
Do you want
to show them what...?
-Why would you make
this book for children?
Why? Why would you...?
Why?
-That's crazy!
-Why would you...?
This is not -- This is...
This is not...
-I mean, yeah,
if it's like, look,
even if I don't like poems,
like, it's a no-brainer.
-I'd go with the poetry book.
-And then this...
And, again, I understand there's
a lot of books about, like,
going to the bathroom
is a hard thing for kids to get.
So I'm not judging that it's
about going to the bathroom.
But "That's right, Esme,
the Toilet Has Teeth."
-Why would you teach...?
Why would you show kids...?
That's not a thing
that you want to do.
-Yeah!
I would think this would --
-This is our competition.
-Yeah.
-We're golden.
-What a good month.
-Yes.
-And then sometimes, like,
there's, like, promotional
tie-ins with film or TV.
-Sure.
-And I think that pays off.
You know, if there's a big kids
movie coming out and, like,
you get a book and, you know,
the kids get to see it.
But I can't imagine that
there's any parent out there
that wants to get their kid
"Li'l Oppenheimer
and His Big Booming Bomb."
-Why would you want
to give the kid that?
That's not a good thing
for the kid to have!
-It's not a good thing for kids!
[ Both speaking shrilly ]
-Go to the last page of this.
-I don't even want to,
because I am like,
"How do you even teach kids...?"
-This is for children.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
You're telling me this is
the last page of this book?
-Show them.
-I mean, I will,
but I'm worried.
-"...and everybody will die.
Everybody.
The end."
-I mean, what? Come on.
I mean, it's "Zilot"
or nothing this month.
This month,
it's "Zilot" or nothing.
You guys, Bob Odenkirk!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Zilot" is on sale now.
We'll be right back with "SNL's"
Marcello Hernandez.